all right first we gotta talk about
asian snacks so many asian kids like
myself when we brought these snacks to
school we used to get made fun of right
because the kids wouldn't know what they
were so now we're here to demystify them
let's start with pocky's these are sweet
they're delicious they're crunchy
just the way i remember them
representation matters and it's about
more than just you know actors on a
screen it's about snacks it's about food
it's about culture in every possible way
japanese rice crackers they're like
wonderfully sweet savory kind of rice
cakes shredded squid
absolutely delicious don't give me that
look i know you're giving that look
right now from across the screen
white rabbit candy otherwise known as da
by tulle delicious iconic lemon tea
drink from veda lunchbox staple and my
personal favorite shrimp crackers shrimp
crackers is actually exactly what i was
eating when i got the call that i was
gonna play chongqi
[Music]
the millennium puzzle
this is the um the chain that yu-gi-oh
had on the actual chain that yukio had
on this was like a tribute piece kind of
me and juice world was talking about him
getting this piece in general and since
he wasn't able to do it i just decided
to do it myself and it's also like a
really big thing of my childhood like
yu-gi-oh was a really big thing in my
childhood i never used to have cable so
i used to watch like cbs and i had to
wait the saturday mornings for it to
come on and like i used to dream about
waking up and watching that so yeah
definitely yu-gi-oh peace
[Music]
here's another thing i'll talk about
if you change your socks in the middle
of the day it changes your whole day i'm
always telling my friends that carry a
pair of socks with you and halfway
through the day just put on a new pair
of socks
you're like a whole new person i've been
doing this for like 15 years or so and
uh i always have an extra pair of socks
on me i don't have particularly sweaty
feet that's not what it is i don't want
people to watch this video and be like
oh i don't need this because camille's
got sweaty smelly feet i don't have
sweaty feet and honestly my feet don't
smell i think it's like just uh whenever
you think of it whenever you feel like
you need like a little jewel to your day
you know i'm realizing how depressing it
is
that
when i want
real excitement to show up in my day i
put on a new fresh pair of socks
ugh i should get out more i should try
some drugs i've heard those are fun
[Music]
this bad boy right here is my ps5 my
playstation 5.
this is an essential to my day i mean
like whenever i go home and uh and i
have some chill time i'm right in my
bedroom playing this [ __ ] i'm playing 2k
because i'm trying to get really good
growing up i
was terrible at games and i i never
really played games that much and i yeah
at least i i wasn't good at them at all
now in my in my free time i've just
become a [ __ ] 2k addict and now i'm
like trying to be like the greatest 2k
player of all time and i i don't know
i'd like to think i'm on my way
man my life has been
very blessed i have seen people from all
walks of life
and realize that just like you know when
you watch forrest gump he just will run
across all these historic moments
i want to document it these cameras are
special because
you can take a photo
and document the moment and give it to
the person and i just have
over the last few years
so many incredible moments captured with
this camera and a few others i just felt
like i need to be capturing this stuff i
feel like forrest gump i feel like gump
in this mug when i was a kid growing up
we have all these photos and you know
after hurricane katrina we lost a lot of
pictures this life is so fleeting right
and you get to these moments where you
can see
things that were important to you
in a picture
and it just brings you to a perspective
of how special it is to be here see it's
coming together see it
man it's coming together
[Music]
this is kind of like my
singing goodies i've got um this manuka
honey
which is so delicious it's actually like
dessert i'm gonna have it right now
[Music]
it's so good
just honey
throw coat
singers necessities
greta's pastilles
also singer necessities
and this is a brand new box
of entertainer secret spray and this i
will use if i like the other day i did
james corden uh crosswalk the musical
and i just had absolutely no voice and
that is like the most stressful
situation ever for a singer when you
have to sing and you're like it's not
coming out and this is kind of like a
little miracle i don't use it all the
time but dry throat and hoarse voice and
it just will kind of throat what coat
toe coat so that's my little
singer's pouch
[Music]
here i got my bogey boys golf balls
i have become obsessed with golf in the
last
two years
and starting a brand called buggy boys
these are our pro-v ones i actually drew
that little dog on the front of it that
little cute-ass dog playing golf god
what a character these are our
own balls and inside of here
more lv
i have
bogey boys
golf balls
they got the bb on them
and i always carry
the special ball this was given to me by
my mother-in-law
thanks sam
jordan ones
um these are the trophy room jordan ones
collab they're sweet the little dirty i
wore these shoes at lollapalooza we got
a signature right here a little sparkly
i don't know if you can see that on
camera when you look at them straight
they're like not color but if you move
they sparkle every show for the most
part i'm gonna be wearing jordan ones
they're just super comfy and durable
i can move around when i lace them up
like tight i can move around feels good
and this is definitely essential to a
show i like like simple like nothing
crazy colors and stuff like that so
anything with the
white as the main and then the colors i
i really like how many jordan ones i own
i own probably about around 50 pairs
easily
[Music]
my next item is something that means a
lot to me like
it's a card from my aunt
she like my mama too at the same time
she's been fighting cancer and she's
super strong
and it's just she said some real
meaningful words in her so it's like
when i get down or when i feel like i'm
against the world ain't nobody
understanding me don't nobody get me
nobody in my corner i had to remind
myself like i got real love so i keep
this with me and i read it like i don't
take it everywhere i go but i gotta read
it and keep it like
keep it close
she gave me this for valentine's day
it's a valentine's day card she told me
i was a valentine
shot my auntie until you read them
[Music]
my last essential is my surfboard this
is what i'm currently riding shout out
to 88 surfboards i like riding foamies
i'm only two years into surfing whenever
i ride a foamy i go for more waves i
feel more like if i [ __ ] up or if
something bad happens i'm not going to
hurt anyone or hurt myself what i love
about 88 is you should watch their
videos their whole ethic is having fun
they're like serious aussie surfers that
grew up in all the harshness of surf
culture they can rip on anything but
they're like we just want to have fun
and ride foamies and i just
like [ __ ] life is so serious like i
just want to try and have a good time
and smile
[Music]